si on passe à tout autre chose avec du
cinéma je vais bien ne t'en fais pas
c'est le titre du dernier film de
philippe lioret
d'après un roman d'olivier adam
l'histoire d'une jeune fille dont le
jumeau a disparu suite à une dispute
familiale sans nouvelles de son frère
lily est sombre dans l'anorexie
dominique poncet et loïc le moigne de ta
faute si les partis n'entrent en
rentrant de vacances
lille y apprend que son frère jumeau a
quitté la maison familiale après une
dispute avec son père mais très vite la
jeune fille va pressentir que le mutisme
de ses parents comme un vrai drame pour
son nouveau film philippe lioret a
choisi de traiter de la disparition d'un
proche et de la dévastation
psychologique qu'elle suscite
avec un tel sujet on pouvait craindre un
film démonstratif et lourd
je vais bien ne t'en fais pas et d'une
pudeur et d'une fluidité éblouissante
voulais que ça soit juste quoi il est
qu'elle révèle ajustées ce qu'on arrive
à s'identifier
parce que nous tous dans la vie je pense
qu'on parle d'eux juste donc fait que la
justice suédoise est dedans tout dans
les décors ni par les costumes
évidemment dans les acteurs
et précisément si le film touche autant
c'est qu'il est porté par des comédiens
au sommet de leur art mention
particulière pour cadres notamment mon
père brisé qui s'oblige à intérioriser
sa douleur la course avant-hier j'ai
vécu dans un petit pavillon aussi de
banlieue à ya quelques kilomètres de
paris mais pas vraiment parisiens n'ont
plus à prendre le le train de banlieue
pour aller bosser j'ai connu ce donc
finalement je me suis beaucoup inspiré
quand même de ce que je connaissais
mention particulière aussi et surtout
pour mélanie laurent qui campe avec un
naturel et une émotion magnifique
cherchent qu à l'héroïne
si sa cage et du film qui s'appelle la
jupe a essayé de jouer la pudeur j'ai
pas essayé de jouer des choses je me
suis laissé porter par un texte que j'ai
trouvé extrêmement juste voilà tout ça
au moins deux d'un résultat très
exigeant avant ce film mélanie laurent
n'était qu'une charmante débutante
elles forment désormais parmi les plus
grandes sur le grand écran c'est sûr on
n'a pas fini de la revoir